مساء الخير فاجات الحكومه المصريه الجميع
بقرار غير مسبوق وهو تحرير العمله المصريه
او الجنه المصري تحريرا كاملا على عكس
معظم التوقعات اللي كانت بتذهب الى ان
الحكومه المصريه لا تستطيع اكثر من تخفيض
قيمه الجنيه قدام الدولار ايه الفرق ما
بين التخفيض وما بين التحرير الكامل
واسباب اللي دفعت الحكومه لهذا القرار غير
المتوقع والنتائج المترتبه عليه هو موضوع
حلقتنا النهارده المساله باختصار انه
الجنيه المصري كان بيعاني من ضغط شديد جدا
وانخفاض وتراجع قيمته بشكل مضطرد ومستمر
قدام الدولار الجنيه كان بينخ فض ليه قدام
الدولار الاسباب معروفه وقلناها اكثر من
مره هي تراجع كل الموارد الدولاريه اللي
بتحصل مصر من خلالها على الدولار زي
السياحه وزي الصادرات وزي الاستثمار
وعائدات المصريين من الخارج لكن كمان كان
في اسباب اخرى هو احجام عدد كبير من
المصريين فضلا المصريين الاول عن ايداع
اموالهم في البنوك بسبب ان البنك بيصر
على يعني على قيمه غير حقيقيه هو 9 جنيه
بينما كان السوق السودا كان بيقدم تقريبا
ضعف هذا المبلغ هو 18 جنيه مقابل الدولار
فكان الناس بيذهب ولا السوق السوداء كل ده
حرم البنك طبعا فضلا عن احجام المستثمرين
منذ فتره طويله عن الاستثمار في مصر بسبب
وجود سعرين سعر غير حقيقي في البنوك وهو 9
جنيه فيما انه السوق السوداء سوق يعني
طبعا له قيم متغيره وبالتالي هم مش عارفين
اي قيمه
ممكن يحددوا حساباتهم على اساسها بالاساس
يعني ايه الحكومه ليه كانت بت تبقي او ليه
فشل النظام اللي كانت بتتبعه من عده سنوات
خصوصا بعد 25 يناير 2011 علشان نفهم القصه
دي نفهم الفرق ما بين التعويم المضار
والتعويم المطلق قبل 3 نوفمبر الماضي اللي
هو من عده ايام كانت الحكومه بتتبع ما
يسمى في السياسه النقديه بالتعويم المضار
التعويم المضار يعني ان الحكومه تستهدف
سعر تعتقد انه عادل لعملتها امام الدولار
اللي هو عمله الاحتياط العالمي المرجعيه
اللي يساوي الذهب قبل سنه
1970 طيب لما بتستهدف السعر ده بتستهدف مش
كده
يعني وفقا لاواه ولكن وفقا ل حسابات دقيقه
جدا بتاخد عده معايير على اساسها بتحدد
حسابات فنيه بتحدد ان السعر العادل لعمتي
امام الدولار او اي عمله اخرى بيتم ربط
العمله بها عند قدر معين في حاله الجنيه
المصري كانت الحكومه المصريه ثبتته عند 9
جنيه تقريبا او 8 جنيه 880 طيب علشان اي
حكومه يكون التثبيت او قرار التعويم
المضار وليه بيسموه مضار بيسموه مضار لانه
الحكومه بتستهدف رقم معين وبعدين بتعيد
النظر فيه من وقت لاخر ثم تحافظ على الرقم
دوت بعده
وسائل الى حين ان هي تشوف ان الرقم ده ل
يعد واقعيا فتعيد النظر اليه مضار لانه
كمان الحكومه لما بتستقل على رقم تراه
عادلا بتتبع عده وسائل للحفاظ على هذا
الرقم منها ان تضخ قدر كافي من الدولارات
علشان تحافظ على قيمه العمله عند الرقم ده
يعني مثلا بالنسبه لمصر كانت قيمه العمله
9 جنيه في البنوك او في السوق الرسمي فكان
لازم
عليها ان تدخ قدر كبير من دولارات توفره
في السوق بقدر معين بحيث يظل كل دولار
يساوي تسع جنيهات لو هي ضخت قدر كبير من
الدولارات هيبقى قيمه الجنيه تبقى اكبر
فكل دولار ممكن يساوي 7 جنيه او يساوي 6
جنيه زي الوضع في السعوديه اللي بتضخ قدر
معين بحيث يكون الريال عند لاثه كل دولار
بيساوي 3.7 ريال اذا قل الكميه اللي بتضخ
كما حدث في مصر بتكون الرقم ده لازم يتخفى
فبدل الدولار ما يساوي 9 جنيه يساوي 10
يساوي 12 يساوي 15 اللي حصل في مصر ان
الحكومه كانت مصره او البنك المركزي مصر
لاسباب وخوفا من ارتفاع الاسعار وانفلات
انه يبقي على الجنيه عند 9 جنيه مقابل
الدولار وما قدرش انه يعزز القيمه دي بانه
يطرح كم كافي من الدولارات ما قدرش يطرح
كم كافي من الدولارات للاسباب اللي ذكرتها
لحضرتكم انه ما عندوش موارد دولاريه
النتيجه انه البنك بيكتب على شاشاته ان
الدولار بيساوي 9 جنيه او
888 فيجي اي مستورد او اي مواطن او اي
مستورد يطلب الدولار بهذه القيمه فلا
يجد النتيجه انه بيذهب الى السوق السوداء
اللي المحافظ او البنك المركزي احيانا
بيقولها علنا دبروا احتياجاتكم كما تريدون
باستثناء الاحتياجات الاساسيه جدا اللي
تتعلق بال الادويه ببعض انواع الادويه
وبعض انواع الاغذيه خلاف كده الناس كانت
بتدبر احتياجاتها من السوق السودا السوق
السودا بقت السعر قفس فيها كان بيتحرك كل
يوم في الايام اللي سبقت عمليه تعويم الى
ان وصل ضعف السوق الرسمي بقى 9 جنيه في
السوق الرسمي 18 جنيه في السوق السوداء
كان متوقع من الحكومه ان تلجا الى مزيد من
التخفيض يعني بدل الجنيه ما يبقى بتسعه
توقعوا ان هم يخفضه الى مستوى 14 13 15
وكان الخلاف هم هيخف عند عند قد ايه
الحكومه كانت مستحيل تلجا للخيار ده لان
اي رقم كانت الحكومه هتستقر عنده حتى ولو
كان 20 جنيه كانت الحكومه هتحاول تحافظ
عليه هتقول سي مثلا ان الدولار ب 20 جنيه
فالناس هيجي يطلبوا الدولارات هتوفر لهم
شهر اثنين لاثه وبعد كده هتعجب لان ما
عندهاش دولارات قدر كفايه فالنتيجه
الدولار هيبقى ب 20 جنيه في البنك بس بس
ما فيش دولارات فهيبقى الناس هتروح للسوق
السودا وال الجنيه ينخفض اكتر واكثر
ويساوي 25 و30 و35 وهنفضل في سباق محموم
يقود كل يعني البلتي او الاستقرار في
الاسواق وبالتالي يعني يعيث الفوضه في
المجتمع فكانت الفكره الخطوه اللي اتخذها
البنك المركزي وانا بعتبرها خطوه يائسه
لانه ما كانش قدامه خيار اخر وهو ان يلجا
الى عمليه التحرير الكامل للعمله المصريه
وهو خيار لم يكن متاحا الا
للدول حاجه من الاثنين اما الدول القويه
جدا اللي عندها اقتصاد قوي ومتنوع
وبالتالي بتحرر العمله بتاعها زي بريطانيا
زي الولايات المتحده زي كندا لانه عندها
اقتصادات متنوعه فايا كانت التغيرات في
العمله هتفضل تغيرات محدوده او الدول
اليائسه زي نيجيريا زي مصر نيجيريا برده
لج وبعدين تراجعت الى التحرير الكامل ثم
تراجعت مؤخرا يعني احنا كمان لجانا الى
عمليه التحرير الكامل اللي معناه ايه ان
انا البنك المركزي لا يستهدف سعر
معين ولكن بيترك المساله للعرض والطلب اذا
كان النهارده في طلب كبير على الدولار
الدولار ارتفع جدا قدام الجنيه وممكن
الدولار يساوي 16 و17 و20 النهارده في طلب
قليل على الدولار فممكن تنخفض الطلب على
الجنيه ويبقى ب 12
و1 ليه البنك المركزي وجد ان ده الخيار
الوحيد وما كانش قدامه خيار اخر اولا قلت
لكم التعويم المضار مش هيقدر عليه لانه ما
عندوش دولارات التحرير الكامل بالنسبه له
بيحمل مزايا محدده واحده منها انه هيقضي
تماما على السوق السودا اللي هو احد
الاسباب الرئيسيه للتشوه اللي موجود في
السياسه النقديه او في سعر سعر الصرف لانه
ماعادش في اي مبار ان الناس تروح للسوق
السودا كل اللي محتاج دولار او اللي عاوز
يوضع دولار هيروح للبنك ويبيعه ل البنك
وبالتالي بدل ما بيبيع في السوق السودا
وياخد مخاطره لا هو هيبيع في السوق الرسمي
فانتقل السوق السوده الى السوق الرسمي بقى
سوق بيضاء الامر الثاني انه يامل انه خد
مجموعه كبيره من الاجراءات المشجعه اللي
بتخدم على قراره زي انه زود الفائده على
اشكال كثيره من ال اوعيه الادخاريه
بالجنيه وارتفعت بعضها الى ان وصل الى 20%
فوائد على بعض الاوعيه الادخاريه بالجنيه
عشان يشجع الناس تسيب الدولار وتحول
فلوسها الى جنيه مثلا خد اجراءات اخرى زي
انه الغى كل الرسوم
وكل الفيز اللي مفروض على تحويلات
المصريين من الخارج املا في ان ده يشجعهم
على ايداع اموالهم
في الجهاز المصرفي خد خطوات كتيره كل
بتشجع طبعا فتح عمل البنوك للسبعه ايام
وتاس مساء كل يوم بما فيها الخميس والجمعه
اسف الجمعه والسبت علشان يفتح المجال
لاكبر يعني يحل محل محلات الصرافه
وبالتالي يقطع الطريق على اي شخص يحتاج في
المرحله دي هو ما بيديش لحد دولار خصوصا
ان اتفق اتفاق جنتلمان الحكومه مع كل
الغرف التجاريه ان يتوقفوا عن الواردات عن
استيراد السلعه غير عن السلعه لمده
اسبوعين
باستثناء الضروريه جدا ويتوقف عن شراء
السلعه التي لها بديل مصري او غير ضروريه
لمده ثلاث شهور اتفاق مع التجار وبالتالي
كل الغرف التجاريه متوافقه وفاهمه انه
لفتره مؤقته سوف يتم التوقف عن الواردات
غير الضروريه للبلد في المرحله دي البنك
المركزي بيجمع دولارات من الناس ما بيدول
لهمش الا للضروره القصوى املا في ان كل
الدولارات اللي قدرت في السوق السوداء في
2015 بحوالي 40 مليار دولار في السوق
السوداء اللي ما حدش عارف عن حاجه تعود
الى المصارف وتعود الى السوق الرسمي فاذا
حدث ده وهو في طريقه الى الحدوث يبقى
النتيجه انه مش هيبقى عندنا ازمه سعر صرف
المشكله الاولانيه ان هيبقى عندنا كافي من
المعروض من الدولار خصوصا اذا ربنا وفق
والاستثمار تشجع بعد الاصلاح في سعر الصرف
واذا عادت السياحه ولو على مراحل الامر
الثاني انه في حاله توفر المعروض من
الدولار معناها انه انا ممكن سعر الجنيه
ينزل بدل ما كان 18 في السوق السودا لا
ممكن ينزل الى مستوى ال جنيه وال 10 جنيه
وال11
جنيه طبعا نتيجه انه التحرير ده حصل ده
كان بيستبح اجراءات اخرى ضروريه جدا ما
ننساش انه الحكومه كانت مضطره اضطرارا
كمان انها تاخذ الخط
دي حتى تقنع صندوق النقد الدولي اللي
هياخد قراره في منح مصر قرض ال 12 مريال
دولار خلال ساعات
قليله كان احد شروط صندوق النقد الدولي
انه لازم انت توحد سعر الصرف ولازم تقلل
دعم الطاقه
فالحكومة
يعني غلت اسعار الوقود بعدها بيوم واحد
اللي هو اليوم التالي يوم 4
نوفمبر في نقطه اساسيه قبل ما انتقل الى
النتائج انه الناس طول الوقت جدل يقول لك
هل ده ده شرط من شروط الصندوق والحكومه
رضخت ليه والحكومه تغل تحلف باغلظ
الايمانات هذا ليس شرطا ونحن لا نرضخ الى
شروط هذا يعني من بنات افكارنا وبكامل
حريتنا والحقيقه هو كل تلاعب بالالفاظ
صحيح ان الصندوق ما قال لهمش لازم تعمله
الحكومه عملت لكن كمان الحكومه عارفه من
كثره تعاملها مع صندوق النقد نقد انه لا
يمكن الصندوق يمنح قرض الى دوله الا اذا
تعهدت
ب تحرير سعر الصرف او على الاقل تخفيض
قيمه العمله بشكل مقبول وتقليل
اسعار وتقليل قيمه الدعم
وتخصيص الشركات والمؤسسات العامه الشركات
الحكوميه الحكومه عارفه كده فبتحب لها
بالفعل اللي في برنامج تقدمه اليها لان
عارفه ان الصندوق لن يتعامل الا اذا
فمفهوم الكلام تسميه بقى شرط تسميه ان
الحكومه عملت الصندوق وافق هو الفكره
واحده الاثنين متوافقين انه مش ممكن
مساعدات
بدون هذه الشروط او هذه الاجراءات
الاستباقيه ماذا يمكن يترتب على ما قامت
به الحكومه ما يترتب عليه انه ضروري جدا
سوف ترتفع كل اسعار السلع والخدمات كل
الاسعار ترتفع
من اكثر الفئات تضررا اكثر الفئات تضررا
هي الطبقه المتوسطه ثم الفقيره واقلهم
الغنيه الطبقه الفق الطبقه الغنيه طبعا
صعب جدا ان تصلها الاثار لانه مش هيتاثر ب
خصوصا ان ههم يملكوا الفئه اللي بتملك
اكبر قدر ممكن من العمله الصعبه الطبقه
الفقيره جدا لن تتاثر بشكل كبير لانه هي
بتحصل على دعم من الحكومه وما بتركب
عربيات يعني لا متوسطه ولا فارهه طبعا طعا
كله هيتاثر لكن الشريحه المتوسطه هي
الاكثر تاثرا وسوف تتاثر بشده جدا مع
ارتفاع كل اسعار السلع والخدمات ليه
الحكومه خاطرت بالخطوه دي اللي ممكن خصوصا
قبل 111 من المتوقع ان الجمعه القادمه
يعني 11/11 خلال ساعات قليله في دعوه الى
التحرك ضد الحكومه والى الثوره عليها
واسقاطها الحكومه خدت الخطوه دي قبل يوم
الجمعه المرتقب 111 لاكثر من سبب اولا هي
مضطره اضرارا والمضطر يركب الصعب ما
عندهاش خيار انها تبقى اكثر من كده خصوصا
زي ما بقول لحضراتكم ان تاجيل الخطوات دي
كان سوف يقطع عليها الحصول على القرض واذا
واذا لم يعطيها صندوق النقد الدولي القرض
معناها انه مش هتقدر تحصل على قروض اخرى
من المجتمع الدولي والمؤسسات الدوليه
باسعار
مقبوله كمان الحكومه ارادت انه توجه رساله
بشكل ضمني ان انا لا اعب ب 11 11 وانا
واثقه من قدره الناس على تفهم ما يجري
هكذا اتصور يعني اما انها عملت كده
بخاطرها او انها
يائسه ايه اللي ممكن كمان يترتب على هذا
القرار كل ما يمكن الخطر الاكبر اللي ممكن
يترتب على هذا القرار مرتبط بقدره الحكومه
خلال الفتره القادمه على احتواء اثار
الغلاء والتضخم اللي نجم عن قراراتها
المتتاليه الكثيره بتطبيق سعر القيمه
المضافه برفع تحرير الجنيه تحريرا كاملا
بتخفيض دعم الوقود بتخفيض دعم الكهرباء
بكل الاجراءات اللي كلها بتصب في كلها
قرارات مؤلمه في رفع تكاليفه المعيشه على
الناس بقدر كبير جدا قدره الحكومه من خلال
عشرات القرارات التي سوف تطلع على احتواء
اثار الغلاء
وتطبيق القرارات ديت بقدر كبير من الكفاءه
واستغلال القرارات ديت لجذب مزيد من
الاستثمارات هو اللي ممكن يؤدي الى واحد
من اثنين اما ان تنجح هذه التجربه وتدخل
هذه الحكومه من باب التاريخ باعتبارها
الحكومه التي نجحت فيما احكمت فيه كل
الحكومات التي سبقتها او لا قدر الله تفشل
وتكون النتيجه غضب عارم جدا من الشعب
عليها يؤدي الى فوضه لا يعلم مداها الا
الله الايام القليله القديمه القليله
القادمه هي التي سوف تكشف عن مدى قدره
الحكومه على اجتياح هذه هذا الاختبار
اشكركم الى لقان اخر ان شاء الله